are you guys doing today good listen
it's always good when you guys are
laughing because you know to start the
interview off let's go with the positive
there we go exactly
I agree so I have to start listen the
movie on this date that we're doing the
interview the movie has crossed over 850
million dollars worldwide which is like
staggering it's the biggest r-rated
movie of all time when you guys first
got involved in this thing like what did
you actually think in terms of like box
office like this might be like a people
might want to see it could make a few
hundred million dollars did you ever
think that it was gonna be as successful
as its turned into not the success has
had currently I think I knew there be a
lot of interest for sure there was
definitely like we're making a movie
about Joker who is as infamous a
character in comic book history there
were a lot of eyes gonna be watching
this movie and that Warner's was making
a pretty safe bet that they'd recoup
some money on it
I thought maybe 300 350 if I was a
betting man so it's about five hundred
more than that I think they're doing
pretty well completely yeah I mean I
don't normally think about box office
when I take on projects but I am I
definitely thought that it was gonna be
a little bit more controversial you know
that there was gonna be a bit more
irritation for the lack of action movie
would disappoint
sort of like the standard-bearer
audience member that I think we've come
to assume is the audience member and I
think one of the surprises of the movie
and a pleasant surprise is that it has
served as an as a sort of a opposite of
this idea that audiences need more more
more action all this like that attention
span is so so short that they need to be
sort of fed information all the time
lots of characters all these things and
this movie sits on the opposite side of
that spectrum and to still have its
success I think is one of the most
wonderful surprises
yeah exactly no I think really I think
the audience probably also just you know
appreciate that that that it's just it's
it's a it's a human movie with real
actors and and no CGI it's it's like
it's it's an actual city it's actually
you know emotions and and and that's
kind of what's what's driving it
completely yeah that's the other thing
that I completely agree with what you're
saying it is a real character study it's
really not one of these every eight
minutes some action set piece I mean it
lives and breathes by Joaquin and
everyone else's performances and it's
amazing that it's done so well you know
I don't know it gives the audience a
little bit of you know because it's it's
rather like slow paced compared to
movies today and I think I always really
appreciate when as an audience twosome
you know if I'm watching something if
I'm taking something in that I have the
time to digest how I feel about things
instead of being force-fed stuff you
know it's like feel this feel this all
the time it is it gives you a bit of
time to to think about what you feel
about what the story hasn't you know it
seems like the audience has appreciated
that yeah for sure yeah I I tend to even
in the big movies and so many of our
sort of big releases nowadays are
predicated on these event picture ideas
and this is certainly an event picture
in so much as the event is is Joker
right like that makes it an event
picture sort of by definition but I
found even like let's say the first two
hours of Avengers I don't know how long
it was the last one endgame sure which
was a lot of set up prior to this
massive fight I was so interested in the
set up I was so interested in really
sort of figuring out the emotions of
each one of these characters as they
approached this thing and so this movie
sort of just that setup and I think
audiences appreciated more than I think
we gave him credit for I was going to
say that I've mentioned this to the
people at Marvel do you know when the
Avengers when they were sitting around
on a table and they were talking about
stuff and they're debating who can pick
up the
I said I could watch a two-hour movie
yeah yeah yeah I don't need an action
scene I just want to see them bantering
about going to the movie theaters to see
a movie like just hanging out with them
that's exactly the point yeah exactly
like that was enough right Diana yes a
Jewish thing right exactly ja anyway
that is enough I want to jump backwards
I have individual questions for each of
you I'll start with you you of history
with Todd you've worked with him for a
number of years
how did Todd first mention to you that
the Joker movie was gonna happen was it
something that like was he casual about
it or you know what I mean like those
first conversation yeah I think he was
super excited that he'd sort of come up
with this idea that he was really happy
with which was I think I found a way in
to get a movie made within this universe
that is obviously the the comic book
universe let's say but his own way and
he's like I think it's really cool it's
like it's basically just a character
study of one of the you know most famous
characters and they told me what it was
and I was like oh my god that sounds
amazing and he's like I think we can do
it if we keep it small enough do it
exactly the way sort of I imagine which
is just really much really just delve
into the mind of Joker and make it
something completely original so he was
he was super excited because I think he
knew he was on to something that would
make for a really good script and was
super castable and he could get mourners
to sign off and make it did he say to
you back then like how does it work with
you guys because you've shot a number of
things yeah do you want to shoot this
it's sort of like you're coming along
just say yes no he actually did say do
you want to shoot this and I said yes
and then he goes I just want to check
because I just want to make sure you
know you've directed before do you want
to shoot this and I was like yes and
he's like because I just want to make
sure do you want to shoot this and I was
like literally like oh you want me to
say no I'm not sure what you did I just
never said no so here I am no I he did
he did actually ask me did I want to and
I was a hundred percent on board but uh
yeah I mean who knows
sure yeah it was it was a funny
conversation because when I hung up I
turned my wife and I was like did he
want me to say no
I figure how long did you know about the
project before it became public
knowledge III read it about a year or so
before we made it I guess so you knows I
was actually in Atlanta making Godzilla
and I guess it was probably around
October so just about a year from when
we actually started principal
photography
had it been announced no maybe a month
or two later maybe a month after that it
was announced God is making this movie
jumping in to how you got involved I
don't believe you've worked with Todd
before so what is that how what was that
first conversation how did you first
connect well he just called me and said
that he was working on a film and I sort
of asked if I was interested in reading
a script then I of course was and and
turned out to be this film and I was I
was really drawn to the script the
script was just it was really fantastic
I think it's one of the best scripts
I've ever read it was really really
really Truman and and then he asked if I
was interested in doing some music based
on what I felt from the script so I
think he was kind of curious to hear how
I heard the script on how I heard the
story and so I wrote a bunch of music
that entered up being the kind of core
core music that was that was in the but
kind of the the the bones of the of the
whole score and yeah so they used a lot
of the music while they were shooting
and I think it was pretty influential
and a lot of the performances in the
film I want to go backwards though do
you know how it was that he connected
with you did was it like an agent was it
that he'd heard something else you done
like he heard the music from Sicario or
you know yeah I think he went to the UM
so he went to this he saw Sicario and in
the cinema I think it was so he must
have been like April when he called me I
think you guys started shooting and like
prepping in May
we just started right at the beginning
of October Oh September September 11th
was actually our first day of shooting
right yeah yeah so I started to probably
like in in yeah in April and and he so I
think he had just like seen Sicario too
sometime before that and then he really
liked that and then he started listening
to my albums which he which he really
liked and then his music editor Jason
Reuter is someone who's worked on pretty
much all of the films he's done the last
ten years and he was he was also kind of
very drawn to my music so I think they
had a conversation about it that I was
probably the right person for the job so
so um yeah so I think that's that's how
they phoned me one of the things that's
great about talking to you guys about
the movie today after it's made almost a
billion dollars which is insane is
everyone seen it so now we can go into
the spoiler territory I'm one of the
things that I think is fantastic about
the film one of the many things is that
you can make the argument that
everything that happened in the movie
actually happened and you can make just
as valid an argument that nothing in the
movie happened that it was all in his
head he's in Arkham imagining things
yeah personally do you have a take on do
you think he actually did these things
do you think this is real do you think
it is all in his head have you ever said
publicly like what your internal
thoughts are well I think I think that's
the magic of a fiction is is that you
know it can be anything I mean all
fiction can be you know can have
happened and I mean it's fiction of
course so it's obviously it is not real
but you know I think sometimes you feel
it's real and sometimes you feel it's
it's fiction but sometimes it you know
it doesn't really even I think it
doesn't even matter it's just like you
know you're just drawn into the story
and the beauty of fiction is like you
know it takes you out of the real world
and you're just like in this in this
world where you're just outside of
everything that that
yeah that doesn't matter really never
take on it or do you like yeah I do ever
take actually and again it's just a
personal perspective because I think
other people can like you said make the
exact argument opposite of this I
believe it happened I believe it
happened in part because I also I find
movies that in which is like it was all
a dream
outside of The Wizard of Oz which is
pretty good I find them to be
unsatisfying I find them to be a little
bit unsatisfying because I feel like
you're taking me on this journey and I
like to believe what I'm seeing has some
cause and effect to other people's lives
and not just in the mind of the person
telling it so I like to believe that it
happened sure that's my personal
perspective what's interesting about the
film though is that I think there are
scenes in the film that you can make the
argument that different things exactly
like for example the veteran again let's
just talk spoilers the very end of the
film yeah when he's in Arkham and he is
going down that hallway after talking to
the woman Todd and Joaquin said that
when they shot it and you know this
obviously is that every take was
completely different so what's great
about that is like I think him in the
hallway is just who the hell knows what
that is that that's probably an
unreliable narrator but him sitting in
the talking to the person in the room I
think is real yeah I think that's a
great perspective on yeah exactly
that's an example of like you could also
yes of course like that's that's your
perspective on it but it's also
beautiful because I think a lot of a lot
of things changed a lot of things about
reality changed throughout like from the
script to the shooting I remember like
the day when I would I camera Seth
thought was kind of running around cuz
he's like yeah we're changing the whole
selfie narrative and like that Sun and
you know it's like okay where's that
gonna go and then it was you know became
this question of like you say if she's
real or not real and and you know
because in the in the script she was
real and then she became not real and
and that's where I think where it's it's
so beautiful that when that twists
happen and it just like holy [ __ ] that
wasn't real like that was all you know
yeah I was all made up that kind of it
kind of that's what I'm saying that it
doesn't really matter if it's real or if
it's not because it's like it's taking
you out there and it's like some parts
could be real like these parts are maybe
not real and then and that's just kind
of a part of the beauty is like what
what just happened there he knows it's
him
yeah and that was a large part of the
movie was was actually adjusting it in
real time like the script as Hildur said
is fantastic and from the script alone
you go we can make a fantastic movie but
the fact that and it's one of the best
things that I've taught as a filmmaker
is he's really open and in fact not just
open but makes it a big part of his
filmmaking experience to constantly sort
of adjust the making of the movie and
the narrative as you make it and and
it's sort of a real time experiment
it's interesting you know one of the
things because of that we shot the movie
out of order which is more common than
shooting it in order but one of the
things that was beneficial about that
was that Joaquin was able to explore
things like the bathroom scene and what
Childers music really informed that
entire scene right prior to that we were
shooting scenes as scripted adjusting
them but also is the discovery of who
arthur is and then and then we we did
that scene which which had it at some
play and then he got to play Joker for
like a week when we shot Murray Franklin
and then the rest of the movie now is
being informed by two versions of what
he's done and so you're able to now make
adjustments in real time and and I think
that's that the movie as a result of all
those things and all those adjustments
that were happening throughout the
making in the movie all the way up until
the last day no it's it was a beautiful
beautiful filmmaking process I think
where as you're saying like all the
elements had such so much space to grow
and to really like there's so much
thrust to all the people involved and
just like gives you so much space to
grow with the whole process of making
the film it's like none of the elements
you first were like running after
everything which is like faster every
every single element just had so much
space to grow in the hole and
process I think that's what at least for
me made it really special because you
know soft and then the music is kind of
running after the the last that it
imposed but but for me to buy have been
such a big part of the whole process
because as you were saying like you know
because I had I had written this music
just kind of from from what I imagined
from from you know I imagine the this
kind of pace and this kind of feeling
and this sort of mindset for him to be
in and then you know he's using that on
Sat and I can really inform all the
elements on set and then they started
sending me daily it's like the bathroom
scene from simple was the first the
first scene that they sent back to me
and it was just like so magnificent to
to see like wow this is exactly what I
had in mind because I I never really
spoke to thought about it like when I
sent in the music I was like he's just
gonna think I'm some weirdo from from my
so he's never gonna want to work if I
tell him what went through my head with
all these like movements and like all
these all these feelings that I had
behind it I was like holy [ __ ] this is
exactly this is exactly what I felt and
working with just like dancing what I
felt and it was just unbelievable to
feel how all of that grew without even
ever having a dialogue about it you know
it was just such a special process and
then as I started to receive the dailies
you know I could also start responding
to the cinematography and and the
choreography and the feeling like as I
was expanding the you know the themes
and the orchestration and inner so I
could really kind of follow what they
were doing us at from from from my
studio and it was just a really yeah it
makes such a difference you know as
opposed to the traditional thing where
some directors will play music that
might inform the pace of the scene or
certainly temp which is really hard for
a composer to deal with but in this case
you know we were able to use your your
music and that's certainly that piece it
helps you realize its effect on both the
actor the camera pacing the movement
yeah it's like it's basically you know
and sometimes we would just have it in
our earpieces piped into the actual
underneath the dialogue track so it felt
like suddenly you were as you're making
the movie you're also watching the final
movie which is has such an influence
on the final product I want to ask you
guys the thing about every movie is the
editing room you know it's the final
rewrites so much can change for both of
you did you end up do you remember a lot
of deleted scenes that you were sad to
see go and I'm curious how much did you
end up scoring of stuff that like didn't
end up making the final movie you know
there's that delicate thing where all of
a sudden you might he might pull
something out and then you have to
rework a whole thing yeah you know it's
interesting cuz I was done six moves
with Todd I had certainly a very early
screening with Todd like very very early
in which I watched the movie in its
forum post sort of assembly and Todd's
really good he works differently than a
lot of directors I've worked with which
is he goes real by real sometimes you'll
sort of massage scenes get it sort of to
us shorter length he just systematically
goes through until he gets to basically
his first assembly is a very very strong
cut as is I watched that cut gave a
bunch of notes and then I didn't watch
another cut until the end until it was
like effectively the cut that it is now
and it's hard for me ever to press any
scenes back in the movie that I don't
think have real necessity emotionally
like there's not something there was
some scenes we shot we shot a scene with
with him in the bank with Sophie that to
me is like a wonderful piece of dailies
it was like probably our first week of
shooting and it was like it's I saw the
cut version of that scene cuz we cut it
early and I still wish that scene could
just we could just watch it as film fans
watching Joaquin Phoenix work because
it's a really lovely scene but it has no
place in the movie now you know and
there's nothing really that I saw get
dropped from the movie that really has
any place in the final movie because the
movies really tight I agree you know and
it's like you could make an argument but
it doesn't it doesn't appreciably make
the movie better so something I missed
there's like one wide shot I wish he put
in God said to me maybe was Joaquin that
uh that when he came out for the Murray
Franklin show like 13 times each one was
different
he's like I'm he said that's like a
two-minute montage he has of all the alt
versions of him coming out yeah and like
as a film fan how fun would be just to
watch all those versions right I said
Jimmy needs to put it on Instagram well
it's like because you can watch this
master actor kind of do something sort
of interesting each one is its own could
make an argument should be in the movie
right it's not like one was bad so yeah
I mean they'll probably never see the
light of day what was it like for you
because you know you know you're
obviously writing and then you have
music and then he's doing another edit
and you have to tighten it up or make
some changes so what was that process
like well the great thing about starting
so early and the great thing about like
setting the tone so earlier was that
like the tone was there from the
beginning like and then the kind of the
feel of the score was there from
beginning so that made the whole process
you know everything that followed after
made it kind of a lot easier because I
wasn't you know I didn't have to spend
any time like figuring out what story I
was telling you know I always knew that
but of course um I mean if it's a movie
so you know a lot of stuff changes all
the time and and so there was definitely
a lot of well not luck but they were
there were like a few kind of problem
scenes with that with a score but they
were normally like not very important
things actually no it was mostly kind of
like travel scenes that we had to kind
of rewrite quite often but because it
was it was kind of you know the scenes
that place you in like okay now you're
going here there was yeah it's really
similar that wasn't like you know wasn't
exactly like in his head but like
outside of him you know that was kind of
those were the scenes that kind of took
sometimes a little time to find the
right way I had to score and then of
course the ending was you know this long
montage in there and then you know when
when he's dancing on the car and all of
that like we went through quite a few
versions of that and the music and that
and that scene it was like I mean I
think the whole the first version of
that scene must have been
ten minutes or something so it was like
this ridiculously long sweet yeah yeah
yeah no I mean it was like a whole kind
of non dialogue musical suite with you
know his him like you know dancing on
all these cars and all these people
what's funny is I literally my for my
next question no BS is what went into
the scene at the end when the Joker
stood on the cop car and smeared blood
on his face because between the
cinematography and the music it's this
exceptional scene with no dialogue
yes no and it's thrilling I mean I
actually as a just a film fan I was
obviously you know knew every part of
the scene and was there photographing
and everything and it still had so much
impact for me as an audience member when
I saw that like with a crowd of people
it was thrilling it's like operatic and
it really it's like there's such a sense
of satisfaction you feel as an audience
member to get to that moment like it
really is thrilling I think that scene
is one of the things I'm impressed about
the movie and in part it's the score in
part it's the editing it's all of it is
just the slow burn that it is and that
the winds are small and there and the
but cumulatively
you can get to a moment like that and
have such power
you know as if you just you know took
out that nose I don't know
I mean musically it was it was kind of
it was for me like his character was so
you know he's so direct
he's so just like kind of you know
simple at heart and just really trying
to understand what's happening and you
should like why don't I fit in why don't
I fit
why don't you know then he starts to
understand more and more but what's
happened to him and I think all of that
required like so much simplicity and so
the older melodies are just like almost
have no harmonious it's just like him
going through a thought process that's
just like very kind of linear and very
kind of almost monotonic you know and
then for the end when all of the
elements of him you know where he's
understood all of his
that are like you know coming together
and his anger and frustration has kind
of just taken over and he's become this
this multi-dimensional character which
but she he didn't really start out to be
then I was just like okay I'm done
how are you it was it was really fun
because it's just like like you say it
was it was almost like operatic after
after it going through like two hours of
like maybe two harmonies you know it was
just like how many you know takes a
while to get there yeah it's a very slow
meditative you know it takes him a while
to stand up it takes him long and it's
like by the time he does that it's like
it is it's just I think the pace of it
is in large part to us it's success no
it's never rushing no what's interesting
about that scene is that's another scene
that I think you can make a strong
argument never happened that when he is
in the police car going to Arkham you
can make the argument in he's dreaming
or he's thinking and that whole thing
it's in that that's why I think again
the film is so good because we can have
that argument both sides you know but I
think that's exactly it comes comes back
to the what I was saying in the
beginning it's just like I think this
film just gives the audience so much
space to think about like how they are
perceiving historian and exactly ask
this question like is it real is it not
fear like what does this mean was you
know it's just like it really it just
it's a kind of open cameras to what you
what you want to take from it and I
think that's what makes it beautiful you
know it's it's a 100 percent one of the
things that I think people aren't gonna
or maybe they'll realize or not know is
that Joaquin was finding things on set
and being improvising a lot in the
moment and stuff but as a
cinematographer how is it to be
capturing that when you're not exactly
like for example that refrigerator scene
yeah where you don't know Joaquin's
going in the refrigerator and you are
shooting it without knowing where the
end is going so what is that like as a
DP you know what I mean with the Russian
Roulette of every scene yeah it's it's
something that frankly Todd and I have
continue to explore through all of our
movies which is to give as much freedom
to the actors give as much freedom to
Todd and just allow us to put an
environment in place in which we can
explore those things so we like to do
masters we like to run scenes from top
to bottom so because of that often that
first take of whatever we're shooting is
often the first time we're figuring it
out in real time so in this case it was
an extension of that so for me I put I
knew that was gonna be a big part of
making the movie and so a lot of it was
like okay how can I light the spaces in
which it's not lighting at 360 in a flat
way but to light it in a way that he can
basically go anywhere within the space
and they'll still be something dynamic
within the frame to capture it so that I
didn't feel like we had to limit where
Joaquin could go that bad that that um
kitchen thing was part of what we
started doing as we sort of explored and
Todd and Martine started having
conversations about what's happening
with this character and and that later
stuff we shot in the movie was actually
a lot of the stuff in the apartment so
because of that he already knew he's
like this guy's probably suffering from
massive insomnia he hasn't slept in
weeks what would happen what would you
start doing when you when this would
happen and so we would add on little
tidbits each day along with our other
work and say well this was gonna do some
moment here
so we actually shot two things in that
kitchen and the second one was that that
uh climbing into the refrigerator so
Todd was effectively like we're gonna do
something in the kitchen so we just set
up two cameras you know one was through
the like the one LLL elope inand we
designed the sets in such a way that we
knew we could always get the camera a
little further away and not be in front
so we could always master something out
so that little breakfast nook window was
one angle and the other one was through
the door that goes into there and then
we just sort of saw what happened and
you know put it on a slider and allow it
to happen and I had no idea I remember
operating on the B camera which was the
one through the side window and I
literally like rain my head
these are they kicking on when he
disappeared the camera I was on you
don't even see just disappears out of
the frame and I like it leaned over I
think you just called the fridge that
night going I don't know if this will
ever make the movie but that was one of
the most bonkers things ever see he just
like crawled inside of the fridge yeah
surprise that hasn't become like a meet
like a challenge hey a fridge challenge
[Laughter]
is it going inside their fridges the the
thing is interesting is I've spoken to
Deakins before and he he doesn't shoot
coverage guys look one camera and that's
the way it goes and I've spoken other
people like they'll have three four
cameras going to have a lot of coverage
what was it like typically how do you
typically like to work and how was it
for this in terms of what was the most
cameras you had and were you ever just
shooting with one camera yeah many times
we choose one camera
I think for me since I was operating the
B camera I would always jam the B camera
in because and it would often be
literally at the last minute so we would
design the shot as single cameras we
could and then the B camera became like
a more experimental version of the a
camera so everything was designed that
around the a camera because I was
operating the B camera I could throw it
in literally at the last minute and I
knew I was never compromising the a
camera so we made sure no matter what we
were always sometimes when you have
multiple cameras you're getting two
worst shots instead of like you know one
really good one and so the intent was
always make sure we're never
compromising the one camera that's its
intent and then and then the B camera
could just kind of be a little more wild
and adventurous and so that often was an
angle that was really weird or or just
in a position where I could do it and
not be photographing the other camera so
that was our main objective and then I
mean we had eight cameras on Murray
Franklin simply because we had four
cameras actually photographing the show
on every single take they were hidden
inside little prop old 1970s like
cameras pedestal cameras so that was
four cameras and then we had three other
cameras and sometimes we'd have a fourth
one there too so we didn't always shoot
one cameras and
it was also to get a bunch of the
coverage and not have to make Joaquin do
it a thousand times you know sure I'm
curious about your writing process so
how do you typically I've is writing
music similar to I speak to a lot of
screenwriters and they'll talk about how
they'll wake up in the morning and for
the first 3-4 hours of the day they feel
really inspired and they can do it and
at certain point it just sort of ends
the inspiration and I've spoken others
it can do 9:00 to 5:00 like it's their
job writing 9:00 to 5:00 how do you
typically write well I try not to work
crazy long hours because I think that
that doesn't serve my creative process
very well so I think I'm I have a few
hours of like very creative work and
where I normally work pretty fast and I
just have to kind of capture what I'm
what I'm thinking but that kind of that
time period can fluctuate like a lot I
mean if I'm just if I'm editing stuffing
I'll work like crazy long hours but but
for actual like music writing for me
it's a rather it's a pretty a wall I
mean I guess work for everyone it's a
pretty it like delicate process so I
have to I have to come to it with with
with very kind of soft gloves so I just
have to give myself a lot of space like
for example in this in this project I
had to really spend some time just just
sitting down and because you know
obviously I didn't have any footage to
work with so I'm just working with with
what I got from the script and and you
know I just had to spend a lot of time
of channeling how do I feel to be inside
of Arthur's head like what this Arthur's
had sound like and it took it took me a
while to kind of sit with it and you
know play around this stuff until I
until I could have found his notes and
then I was just like it was it was
almost like being punched in the chest
like it came like okay what do you want
to say and I just have to kind of run I
have to capture it you know but it kind
of sometimes it takes a while to get
there and and that's pretty
unpredictable like how how when one that
and but every single project is is is
pretty different you know and for two
Nobel for example which was the last
project I well I worked on
simultaneously with two the Joker that
process was really really different
because that was much more based on
field recordings and and kind of
processing material that I was gathering
from a nuclear power plant you know so
it's a it's a completely different
working process so I tried to just I
tried to approach every project with
very kind of open ears and an open mind
and just like look at what every project
needs for the story to be served best
but um but yeah like I said that just I
tried to give myself as much headspace
as I can within the within the schedule
I'm curious when it comes when you think
back on the writing process of all the
music you did what's the one what's the
piece of music that maybe came the
easiest is there one that just you kept
on going back to like this is not good
this is not good
you know what I mean like drilling down
to try to figure it out well I'm I tend
to if if I if if I start feeling like
this is not good then I I normally just
have to step away from it then then
normally it's it's you know it's then I
just know that it's never gonna be good
if I have to kind of drill on it you
know but um but for example the the
music that this was the music that came
to me to the the bathroom dance scene
that was the first that was the kind of
moment of when I was punched in the
chest you know that that's when I knew
like this is his music like that that is
it and everything else is going to be
based from like this is the starting
point like this is his head you know
these are his emotions and that was like
it was really tear like that was very
obvious and some of the other themes
also came came pretty pretty easily and
I tried to I try not to let anything
like I try not to send anything you know
to the director unless I'm like actually
like really happy with it unless I know
like for for real that is that it's
that it says something behind it
completely I am just otherwise I cannot
live with the tappety like damn why did
I send it were you ever jammed for time
on this movie like did you ever have a
deadline in which he needed one more one
more piece and yeah I need a little more
time or we or was it
no there was definitely some moments of
like yeah down MOBAs I mean no I just
wonder you know it's interesting because
it's a solitary experience for a lot of
it right where you a little write like a
screenwriter would and then sometimes is
the pressure of time I obviously have to
work with time pressure every single day
yeah so it's just an experience that I'm
used to and sometimes the time is a good
thing meaning the lack thereof it's like
it creates forces you to drive in a
direction because you don't have enough
time to explore every single ya know it
definitely it definitely often helps
having I have it creates like a certain
energy we're just like okay what am i
doing what am i doing and he did good
but it definitely helps when when the
beginning stages are you know spacious
and we have a lot of time in the
beginning you know which was the case
for this this project and then it makes
the whole um crunch periods easier
because you can fall back on you know at
least I'm not gonna get fired
exactly when did you stop thinking you
were gonna get robbed
no you know that was the beautiful thing
about this project was that I think the
music in there
thank you I got a wrap up with you guys
but real fast what's the next thing that
you guys have coming up
I have nothing I'm just I'm taking a bit
of a time to to digest everything that's
come out so far so I'm just giving
myself some headspace in the short term
going to pull into camera Maj which is
like a cinematographer which I'm
ecstatic about cuz I've never been and
it's a real celebration under graft and
Joker's gonna play there and excited
about that in the longer term it looks
like there's another the bigger DC
property that I think I'm gonna do I
came not gonna say work it out soon
that's awesome and my last thing for you
I've been asking everyone about this
what TV show would you love to guess
shoot and what TV show would you love to
guest compose that's a great question
yeah shoot the crown love the crown it's
amazing I mean there's so many actually
what I was gonna say it's just like
there's so many out there is that cool
has time to see you yeah yeah yeah yeah
the crown is the first one that came to
my head but yeah yeah god I have no idea
is there anything that you binge watch
recently but you loved
I haven't really had time to watch
anything serious yeah I am
this explains why you're not taking work
but why this year's was was really
really good
which one wait so called why this year's
when this year's know that there was him
that was really good I was done like
that yeah what would I like to compose
it'd have to be something very simple
I'll leave it there and just say I mean
it sincerely both of you guys did such
phenomenal work on this movie I so
appreciate you coming in the studio and
I wish you guys nothing but the best
hey thanks cool and I got to meet hell
they're fun so we don't get to one time
one set it's so crazy that's bonkers
yeah so yes no but sushi Congrats and on
that note thanks everyone for watching